eric coquerel député la france insoumise
de la première circonscription de
seine-saint-denis bonsoir eric coquerel
on a vu que ses habitants ont le
sentiment d'être comme ils disent les
oubliés dans cette crise
edouard philippe a pourtant annoncé une
aide de 150 euros pour les familles
défavorisées 100 euros de plus par
enfant
ils bénéficieront à 4 millions de foyers
en france c'est une mesure que vous
applaudissez tout de même c'est une
mesure nécessaire c'est pas ça qui va
réduire les inégalités mais simplement
nécessaire pour que les gens arrivent à
survivre alors cela dit il va falloir
voir cette mesure comment elle se
concrétise parce que cet après midi on a
étudié le projet de loi de finances
rectificatif à l'assemblée nationale qui
doit être adoptée vendredi et pour ma
part sauf erreur j'ai pas vu trace de
cet argent pour les 3 4 millions de
foyers les plus les plus précaires en
france peut-être de super-g pas regarder
en détail mais je vais regarder avec
attention pour faire en sorte que cette
promesse cette assurance soit se
concrétise alors un autre débat qui fait
rage notamment dans votre département se
retour à l'école le débat divise mais
emmanuel macron a clairement prenait
l'argument social destiné aux familles
les plus défavorisées qu'elle est
quelles sont les réactions autour de
vous est ce que déjà c'est quelque chose
que vous cautionnez dont je crois pas du
tout l argument avancé par le chef de
l'état je crois plutôt que l'école va
être appelé à jouer un rôle de garderie
par rapport à des parents qui soit et
aller travailler parce que en réalité
son annonce sur le 11 mai répond voix
des critères sanitaires je vais y venir
si vous voulez qui a des critères
économiques
il s'agit de relancer la machine
économique et donc on renvoie le
français au travail
toute la question c'est est ce que c'est
vraiment raisonnable de donner ses deux
priorités est ce que cela correspond à
une rationalité des produits sanitaires
ou permettrait d'en douter
tout à l'heure nous avons auditionné à
l'assemblée nationale le responsable du
conseil scientifique qui dit qu il
faudra cent mille tests par jour pour
être dans des conditions à peu près
acceptable proche un peu de ce qui est
toujours lui actuellement le carde
d'allemagne aujourd'hui une trentaine
dont première question est ce qu'on aura
cent mille tests par jour d'ici le 11
mai quand j'observe que l'économie n'a
pas vraiment été réquisitionnés planifié
cette fin deuxième question
effectivement c'est les écoles et j'ai
senti ont tout à l'heure le le président
de ce conseil scientifique qui a
manifestement n'a pas été consultée
position du chef de l'état très réservé
en disant qu' est-ce que en posant la
question lui même est ce que ces
responsables aient en disant qu'il
faudra beaucoup beaucoup de pré requis
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
j'espère qu'ils vont être suivis parce
que pour l'instant j'ai un peu
l'impression que on va cours et à
l'horizon une deuxième vague de
contamination des enfants et 2 les
enfants vers les parents et les
enseignants dans tout ça ne me rassure
pas au bout dans le même temps vous
l'avez d'ailleurs cité l'allemagne
envisage clairement enfin va d'ailleurs
le faire le 4 mai rouvrir partiellement
ces écoles écoles et lycées le danemark
le fait aujourd'hui quel est le problème
en france ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas
pris la crise suffisamment en amont
parce que c'est vrai que confiné les
gens éternellement ce n'est peut-être
pas une solution non plus vous en
conviendrez
ça c'est clair
mais si en france on a été obligé de
d'utiliser la méthode du confinement
global c'est pas j'allais dire par là
d'un impératif sanitaire c'est du fait
qu'on était démuni de beaucoup d'autres
choses
donc ça c'est les responsabilités de
ceux qui gouvernent c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont pas assez anticipé la la situation
l'épidémie et qui ont mis aussi depuis
plusieurs années alors il n'y a pas que
le gouvernement macro ça a commencé
avant l'état de la santé publique de
danse pris dans une situation qui qui
montrait qu'elle ne pouvait pas assumer
un choc de cette ampleur sans justement
des mesures telles que le confinement et
laisser sa différence avec l'année
civile et l'allemagne par exemple
aujourd'hui on nous parle il ya cent
mille tests en allemagne par jour
mandela tranquille et ça fait cent mille
thèse depuis maintenant plusieurs
semaines donc qu'ils avaient déjà
répondu à cette condition
la deuxième c'est quand d'allemagne ils
ont commencé la crise épidémique avec 25
mille lits permettant d respiration
artificielle et c'est nous on avait 5000
donc vous voyez que cette
différenciation explique pourquoi on a
été obligé de confiner tout pays doit
dire recule donc là il ya vraiment des y
aura des comptes à rendre sur la
politique menée en matière de santé
publique notamment donc un déconfinement
également par critère d'âge c'est
quelque chose qui vous semblent
nécessaires ou ça indique une forme de
discrimination peut-être pour les
personnes les plus âgées les plus
fragiles qui vont être confinés jusqu'à
nouvel ordre le professeur delfraissy
savez ça va être très compliqué il m'a
qu'on puisse dire que sur quelques et à
saas fee
comme vous l'avait dit en plus
l'introduction être confiné c'est pas
une situation normale
je m'inquiète aussi d'ailleurs pour les
personnes fragiles parce qu'on nous dit
que devront être resté confiné les
personnes âgées mais aussi les personnes
fragiles par un pan de ceux qui ont des
maladies des maladies sur le long terme
fade et auto immunitaires et sait
comment ça va se passer par rapport aux
employeurs parce que je suppose que don
de ces personnes là n'ont pas être
autorisés à aller travailler et ce qui
touche pause appel de confidentialité
par rapport aux employeurs qui ne
connaissent pas forcément et c'est
normal leur état de santé
voilà tout ça pose des problèmes moi je
crois que
le déconfinement doit répondre d'abord à
des critères sanitaires
c'est à dire suffisamment de tests
suffisamment de masques y compris pour
les personnes fragiles dépistage massif
pas seulement pour les personnes qui
sont un symptôme mais toute personne qui
peut être inquiètés y compris des
populations entières pendante
on parlait de seine-saint-denis je pose
la question est-ce que vu l'état les
inégalités en seine-saint-denis la
question une question sanitaire de deux
pitots de santé publique sont déjà
largement inégale par rapport est
défavorisé par rapport au reste de la
fin est ce qu'on ne devrait pas pouvoir
dépister dois dire plus ma cible la
population de seine saint denis pour ces
raisons donc moi je crois qu'il faut
partir de ces critères
avant de partir de critères économiques
avec l'idée qu'il faut remettre les gens
au travail
dernière question emmanuel macron a fait
allusion faite de se refonder la presse
évoque un gouvernement de de concorde
quel monde d'après selon vous le monde
d'après si on pense qu'il doit être
totalement différent du monde
d'aujourd'hui sur l'austérité celui du
libre marché suivi du profit avant tout
celui du grand déménagement du monde et
c'est à mon avis c'est pas laisser les
partisans de ce monde qui peuvent le
mettre en application que je ne compte
pas sur monsieur macro pour répondre à
ce besoin vous savez en 2008 nicolas
sarkozy avait promis monts et merveilles
par ailleurs il avait un discours quasi
d'extrême gauche après la crise et supra
il est vite revenu à des critères plus
plus plus comment dire libéraux je
dirais qu'il faudra un recours peut-être
envisager des élections anticipées
d'ailleurs pour justement capable de
répondre à cette question et non de côté
ou l'a dit on est on est un recours avec
l'avenir en commun depuis longtemps
justement propose ce monde d'après merci
beaucoup et eric ancré a débuté à la
france 1 sont mises de la première
circonscription à des hauts-de-seine et
seine-saint-denis pardon merci à vous